kurt vonnegut was one of the most
prolific american novelists of the last
century
his writing was unconventional and
thought-provoking
his passages were oozing in motion and
every word was trying to communicate
something more than just its direct
meaning he wanted to inspire
to stimulate attention to help the
reader feel
take this simple yet profound dialogue
between two figures in his
most popular bestseller slaughterhouse
five
why me there is a very earthling
question to ask mr pilgrim
why you why ask for that matter why
anything
because this moment simply is have you
ever seen bugs trapped in number
yes well here we are mr pilgrim
trapped in the amber of this moment
there is no why
or this passage where he explicitly
criticizes the american dream
america is the wealthiest nation on
earth but its people are mainly poor
and poor americans are urged to hate
themselves
to quote the american humorist king
hubbard it ain't no disgrace to be poor
but it might as well be it is in fact a
crime for an american to be poor
even though america is a nation of poor
every other nation has folk traditions
of men who were poor but
extremely wise and virtuous and
therefore more estimable than anyone
with power and gold
no such tales are told by the american
poor they mock themselves and glorify
their betters
the meanest eating or drinking
establishment owned by a man who is
himself poor
is very likely to have a sign on its
wall asking the cruel question
if you're smart why and you rich he is
unflinchingly and
unrelentingly attempting to question the
status quo
and provoke thinking it is this lack of
ordinariness that made him the writer
that was and
is still admired by many it is this lack
of ordinariness that
can make any writer stand out
it was almost 7 years ago when i decided
to start working on my first essay
i remember that moment quite vividly it
took me almost 2 hours to write
200 words to put that in perspective
today whenever i manage to reach a
flow state i can write around a thousand
words within one hour
so let's try and monitor my evolution
throughout the years
here's a small paragraph from one of my
first essays
efficiency what a widely misunderstood
term
i had to go through a lot of stages and
career changes in order to understand
what efficiency is
and how to be properly efficient in
whatever i do
efficiency is closely related to
discipline and focus
it is the process you need to undertake
in order to achieve different goals you
have
these goals can range from starting your
own business or
learning guitar to mastering a specific
craft
this is not a bad paragraph the writing
style is direct and simple
most of the sentences are well connected
and the thoughts are
clearly articulated but one wouldn't
characterize it as great writing because
it is missing some essential ingredients
that can bring one's writing style to a
whole new level
now take a look at the paragraph from an
essay i wrote two years later
becoming enamored with the way your
brain operates can lead to a marvelous
way in the way you manage it
but also in the way you evolve it
although more information
grants us access to more knowledge our
ability to analyze this information is
predicated upon our ability to
understand our cerebral makeup
think of your brain as an uber sensitive
tool that
shapes its form and capacity in
accordance with the
information it gathers nowadays the
information torrent we have to face
has increased dramatically and our brain
struggles to keep up with this
novelty writing well demands a degree of
wholeness
that is it needs to consist of multiple
interconnected elements that
blend together beautifully lashes words
great syntax almost flawless grammar
coherent connections between sentences
that composition will result in a
pleasurable experience
not only for the eyes of the reader but
also for their soul
but to reach such a result you need to
be able to monitor your work and your
own evolution as a writer
identifying points of friction and areas
that are open to improvement
allows you to evolve your writing style
in unprecedented ways
think of writing as any skill that can
be learned and improved
through competence emerges when one is
capable of becoming aware of one's
control
over the skill continuous immersion
offers a level of understanding of the
constituents of the skill
that an untrained eye will never be able
to see
you become the writing and the writing
becomes you
a critical tipping point in my writing
career occurred when i realized that i'm
the amalgamation of my biggest
influencers the writers that inspire me
have such a strong impact on the way i
perceive words
and various writing styles that they
inevitably shape the writer that i am
today
it all started with the fundamentals of
personal growth
books like the four-hour work week by
tim ferriss
how to win friends and influence people
by dale carnegie
mastery by robert greene the power of
now by cartoli
these books really pave the path to what
would later become a more
refined version of myself as a writer
the writing of these authors
wasn't that simple but it wasn't that
complicated either
they constitute the perfect starting
point for every person who is new to
self-development
and can help every young writer
understand how proper writing works
later on i felt that i could stretch my
intellectual limits and dive into the
works of people like
sam harris jordan peterson daniel
goldman
and peter joseph to name but a few these
people examine more
challenging ideas thus the writing
illuminates a level of
intellectual depth very few people in
this world have managed to reach
when one invests the time and effort to
properly construe these ideas
one also increases the probability of
forming similar ones
eventually i started to adopt more
abstract thinking patterns and i decided
to challenge myself with
what i like to call as the pinnacle of
higher thought
this is composed of works produced by
the greatest thinkers and philosophers
across space and time people like
friedrich nietzsche
emmanuel kant arthur schopenhauer carl
jung
sigmund freud and so many others who
devoted their lives to analyzing the
human condition and
making sense of the world around us they
did so in such a potent way that one can
suggest that they
transcended the limits of ordinary
thought when you quote unquote
befriend these figures and make them
your source of inspiration
you can't help but understand that there
is so much more to writing than
mere thought articulation take for
instance this powerful passage from
niches beyond good and evil
it is the business of the very few to be
independent it is a privilege of the
strong
and whoever attempts it even with the
best right but
without being obliged to do so proves
that he is probably not only strong
but also daring beyond measure he enters
into a labyrinth
he multiplies a thousand-fold the
dangers which life
in itself already brings with it not the
list of which is that
no one can see how and where he loses
his way
becomes isolated and stored in piecemeal
by some minotaur of conscience supposing
such a one comes to grief
it is so far from the comprehension of
men that they
neither feel it nor sympathize with it
and he cannot any longer go back
he cannot even go back again to the
sympathy of man
there's so much madness in his writing
but there is also so much truth
in his madness
your language is your main tool for
articulating thought
for instance by adopting a plain english
way of speaking and writing
although you might sound more clear and
concise you're also limiting your
potential for
more elaborate thought articulation life
remains in a stagnant state and
every opportunity to raise your
intellectual standards and
understand reality better becomes
limited because you can't keep up with
complex topics and thought-provoking
ideas
i realized that soon enough and that's
why you will identify many
so called big words in my essays and
videos i do it on purpose
i do it in order to positively provoke
both myself
and my readers that is not an easy task
but i employed a very effective strategy
to achieve that
i read hard books hard books are quite
rigorous in the way the narrative is
presented and
the authors usually use big words in
order to attach
one more layer of grandiosity to their
ideas
hard books have usually such a rare and
beautiful vocabulary that
reading them allows you to re-evaluate
what you know and what you don't know
according to my experience the most
efficacious way of dealing with big
words
is to keep a file on your computer with
words that you like
and feel comfortable using in my file
you can find
words like self-sabotage plausible
deniability
begrudge palatable connotes
adroitly acrimonious imbue
tirade whimsical extirpate
temerity and many more this file is an
essential companion whenever i decide to
start a new essay and
some words just by the way they sound
can spark a new sentence or
even a paragraph let's take for example
the word extirpate
which means eradicate i could easily add
in this section of the video something
along the lines of
the use of big words could extirpate any
sense of
incompetence associated with your lack
of a rich vocabulary
see how the sentence blends in nicely
with the rest of the text and
clearly elevates my writing stature in
the eyes of the reader
sometimes a beautiful sentence is also
the creative boost a writer needs to
stay
dedicated to their endeavor for people
who want to kickstart their attempt to
enrich their vocabulary
i suggest a great book titled 30 days to
a more powerful vocabulary
it was recommended by sam harris in one
of his podcasts
and i really enjoyed reading it stick
till the end of the video for
a giveaway related to the book
ultimately great writing boils down not
to what you write
but how you write it there is a myriad
of topics one can draw inspiration from
and
there will be many people who will
assert that your topic of choice has
been covered
ad nauseum this is irrelevant and these
voices shouldn't be of any concern to
you as a writer
a topic is authentic regardless of its
content
insofar as the writer adds his or her
personal touch to it
nietzsche schopenhauer camus bukowski
the old cover topics revolving around a
similar theme
that of life a struggle no one accused
them of being
banal or repeating the same intellectual
patterns
despite the fact that most were inspired
by their predecessors
the choice of words the emotion elicited
the level
of resonance evokes and the flow created
are all elements that make it work
special and unique
there's only one thing a writer needs to
fight and be constantly aware of
cliches the battle with cliches will be
an omnipresent battle
it is a battle so tiring and difficult
that ultimately
becomes the catalyst that differentiates
good writers
from great ones as a new writer one can
logically wonder
how can one identify cliches in their
writing
a typical example would be to avoid
repetition and use of
conventional wisdom as the basis of your
claims
many people due to their constant
involvement with standardized and
conventional ideas
exhibit a severe lack of innovation in
the way they express themselves
you are more or less what your
experience and knowledge allow you to be
you can expect to rely on banality in
order to
formulate a more advanced level of
reasoning there is no chance that you
will be able to battle cliches that way
take a look at the sentence from the
popular book the secret
there is a truth deep down inside of you
that has been waiting for you to
discover it
and that truth is this you deserve all
good things life has to offer
it is a beautiful sentence that creates
an emotional response when you read it
but
it is the most common motivational motif
ever used
the internet is inundated with this type
of reasoning and
although it has a degree of positivity
and trends to it
it virtually offers zero value to the
reader in a nutshell
it epitomizes the idea of cliches now
take a look at this aphorism from niches
beyond good and evil
beware that when fighting monsters you
yourself do not become a monster
for when you gaze long into the abyss
the abyss
gazes also into you this extraordinary
combination of words
is simply sublime there is so much
meaning behind the words
cliches are nowhere to be found here
they were eradicated simply by the
writer's choice
to reject the norm and think
unconventionally
there are many more things to be
discussed on the topic of how to write
well but i decided to limit my scope of
examination to
four points that i personally consider
more crucial than the rest
in the grand scheme of things one
eventually understands that
good writing is predicated upon the
capacity of the individual to evolve it
this evolution is quite essential to our
own personal evolution
and also quite antithetical to all
things that limit us
it is a tough process albeit an
extremely rewarding one
hey guys so this video is sponsored by
skillshare skillset is an online
learning community with thousands of
inspiring classes for creators
where you can explore new skills and
deepen existing passions and get lost in
creativity
and i think it's a sponsorship that
connects well with the topic of writing
well
jordan peterson has said many times that
to write is to think
and i totally agree i cannot think of
any other skill that can actually
stretch so much your intellectual limits
or
help you think deeper that's why i
suggest people to start writing
anything from journaling to writing
essays or small novels can
really help you discover the depths of
your inner world
and also don't forget that writing is a
therapeutic process
skillset has numerous classes on writing
and journaling that can
either help you start writing or improve
your writing
for instance i really enjoyed this class
by roxanne gay titled
creative writing crafting personal
essays with impact
or this class by emily gould titled
creative writing for all a 10-day
journaling challenge
they're both quite engaging and very
insightful skillshare is created
specifically for learning meaning that
there are no ads and they're always
launching new premium classes so you can
stay focused and
follow wherever your creativity takes
you and it's less than ten dollars a
month with an
annual subscription also i would like to
announce a giveaway with this video
i would like to give away this amazing
book called 30 days to a more powerful
vocabulary
all you need to do to enter is to like
this video subscribe
get notifications comment below and sign
up for skillshare the first 1000
of you to click the link in the
description will get the free trial of
skillshare premium so
act fast i will announce the winner in a
week from now through my instagram page
and i will contact the winner through
the comments so please stay tuned and
turn on your notifications again thanks
for watching see you soon adrian out
you